and looking to do it in backto back
Seasons against this Hawkeye
[Music]
[Applause]
team Kate Martin again taking it out
from the sideline Gabby Marshall back
into the game Clark a long three it's
short once more the long rebound to
Walker and she's going to go up with it
K State takes down Iowa and take notice
of these
[Applause]
[Music]
cats
6558 the final and Iowa has its first
loss of the season the question was do
the Wildcats have enough offense well
they had just enough all they needed
because they locked in on the defensive
end of the floor they dictated Tempo
with their execution offensively this is
a team that is continuing to put the
pieces
together second ranked Iowa Falls to
Kansas State in backto back Seasons a
huge win for the Wildcats are final
score 6558 here in Iowa
City